le 27 novembre dernier le président de
la République Emmanuel Macron annonçait
vouloir développer l'équivalent du RER
francilien dans une dizaine de
métropoles françaises une annonce qui
n'a pas échappé à nos politiques ce
vendredi après-midi les représentants
des collectivités locales concernées se
sont réunis pour évoquer les
possibilités d'action pour développer ce
mode de transport on en parle plus
longuement avec notre invité du jour
Frédéric
oGIS bonjour bonjour vous êtes donc le
président de Tours métropole Val de
Loire en début d'après-midi je le disais
avec notamment le préfet le président de
la région et tous les présidents des
communautés de communes du département
vous avez signé une déclaration
d'intention concernant cette étoile
ferroviaire alors quelle est la portée
du document que vous avez signé alors la
portée juridique elle est pas importante
mais symbolique est très importante
parce que tout le monde était autour de
la table c'est la volonté du territoire
la Touraine d'être dans ce wagon on va
dire de du RER présent la République
comme vous l'avez dit à 27 novembre a
annoncé RR dans les dans les métropoles
et on a considéré que au vu de l'étoile
à 8 branches que l'on constitue et bien
il fallait aller sur ce sur cette grande
politique de mobilité et la métropole
est un acteur important mais les
l'ensemble des étoiles ferroviaires sont
sur les autres intercommunalités qui
nous entourent donc la volonté c'était
tout le monde autour de la table le
maire de tour le maire de
Saint-Pierre-des-Corps les deux gares et
puis le président de la Région François
Benoît était à nos côtés on va la
regarder cette étoile ferroviaire alors
cette carte on l'a on l'a déjà vu mais
on vous la reprise donc
tout ça tout ce qu'on voit là à
l'antenne ce sont des lignes SNCF qui
sont déjà existantes mais dont il
faudrait évidemment doper les cadences
pour pouvoir en faire une sorte de RER
c'est bien ça c'est bien cela c'est
d'avoir des cadencesments plus
importants de pouvoir finalement changer
les modes de mobilité de façon très
positive si vous avez devant chez vous
un train qui passe et au lieu d'en avoir
un le matin le soir vous en avez à
plusieurs heures de la journée et bien
vous changez votre mode de locomotion et
c'est très positif parce qu'on parle de
décarbonation de transport et bien là
c'est un résultat concret d'une volonté
globale d'aller vers cette étoile
ferroviaire elle existe depuis 100 ans
ça fait 30 ans qu'on en parle en
Indre-et-Loire
finalement le catalyseur du président de
la République nous a permis d'aller sur
ce label RER
région et la métropole seront des
financeurs et au-delà de ces financesurs
c'est cette volonté d'aller dans une
étoile ferroviaire qui deviendrait le
quotidien des tourangers les tours en
jours car aujourd'hui souvent on parle
de qu'est-ce qui pourrait mobiliser la
Tourette ça ce projet étoile ferroviaire
mobilise chacun et on l'a bien vu il y
avait tout le monde autour de la table
pour dire que c'est un bon projet quand
on s'est appelé avec Emmanuel Denis pour
dire on peut pas louper les RER j'ai
invité l'ensemble des mes collègues des
interprétés qui ont travaillé et lorsque
nous avions fait métropole nous avions
dit pour les grandes politiques
publiques la métropole sera à vos côtés
les autres intercommunalités et bien là
franchement c'est un projet qui permet
d'envisager différemment les transports
d'ici à 15 ans c'est quoi la suite de la
signature dont que l'on a vu en début
d'entretien quelle suite vous attendez
vous allez l'envoyer à l'état vous
m'attendais une réponse de l'État
on va rencontrer bien sûr des ministres
dans les prochaines semaines pour leur
dire combien le dossier est prêt et
finalement le président de la République
il a dit je voudrais des RER mais il y a
des endroits où c'est il y a pas une
étoile ferroviaire comme la nôtre donc
c'est de dire vous voulez un projet qui
est ambitieux l'ambition elle est
entourée bienvenue aux toile c'est
clairement il y a plus qu'à dérouler
avec la SNCF la région qui a déjà fait
un gros travail parce que la région
Centre-Val de Loire et Jane des seules
régions de France dans lequel on aura
l'expérimentation hydrogène sur
l'horloge vous avez également un
cadencement plus important vers
Montlouis et vert Blois donc tout ça ça
a déjà été anticipé il y a un travail
depuis 2019 de l'étoile ferroviaire
simplement d'avoir le label permet de
mobiliser des fonds publics
qu'aujourd'hui on mettrait beaucoup plus
de temps si elle avait pas de label on a
une idée du coup de tout ça
pour l'instant on en est pas parce qu'il
y a des études qui sont lancées mais en
tout cas
lorsque l'on est métropole il faut avoir
une ambition et cette ambition sur la
mobilité passe pour le tour de bas
carbone et passe par les toiles
ferroviaires donc les fonds seront
facile à mobiliser si on a la belle
quelle est la priorité la deuxième ligne
de tramway ou cette étoile ferroviaire
c'est les calques de la mobilité il y a
un schéma cyclable sur cette métropole
qui est ambitieuse il y a une seconde
ligne tramway il y a des bus à au niveau
de service il y a également le transport
à la demande pour les zones plus
reculées mais qui sont importantes et
l'étoile ferroviaire c'est ce qui vient
un peu chapeauter tout cela parce que il
faudra aussi débuter à la sortie des
gardes pour emmener les gens au plus
près de chez eux donc tout est important
et la mobilité c'est ce qui permet
l'emploi c'est ce qui permet l'éducation
c'est ce qui permet l'enseignement
supérieur donc la mobilité est une des
priorité de notre métropole merci merci
Frédéric Augus pour vous expliquer